so i am at rockefeller right now we are
on the upper east side of new york um
this is my boss's office
um there's some historical memorabilia
behind me
we're going to talk a little bit about
history here
and basically what
we do here in this lab this the lab is
called
laboratory of chromatin biology and
epigenetics
if you guys know what epigenetics is you
can like type in one
in chat if you want if you don't type a
zero
um i will tell you anyway what i think
it is
um so it doesn't really matter
and i guess there's more people joining
in and we're like
basically as
wow there's a lot of people holy moly i
just gave a seminar on zoom there was
like 40 people i thought this was like
the most people i've ever seen in the
zoom but
there's there's still more people coming
anyway
so big picture here and
what we study and what we're trying to
understand is something that has puzzled
people for
you know century probably now once they
figured out that
genetic information is stored in
chromosomes they also realize that
pretty much
all cells in the organism have the same
chromosomes
um but cells are different
so as the organism develops obviously
you know you start getting
neurons and skin cells and bone cells
and blood cells and
you know hundreds you know thousands of
cell types in every organism
but dna is the same which is why you can
catch a
criminal by dna profile or you can do
ancestry by dna profiling and your dna
is not
that different from your mom's dna
whatever but
the cells in your body are completely
different they do completely different
things
so sometimes these things go wrong and
sometimes that causes genetic diseases
which
you know sometimes it's a mutation in
the gene and sometimes it's a mutation
that affects regulation of a gene
and broadly what
has become obvious in the past 50
60 years is that what matters is not
just the gene makeup you have but also
how these genes are regulated which ones
of them are on which ones are off
and how this on off switch
goes you know between different states
you know development disease
and so on so why does a skin cell
express
skin genes why does the brain cell grow
axons and
become a brain cell and
man there's a lot of people and they're
still ding ding ding ding ding
okay so what
people have started working on
a while ago is model organisms because
we
very rarely work on humans um actually
now we do that quite a bit more
because we have a lot of sequencing data
from human patients and from different
diseases and
we can aggregate this like as a big data
thing but
you know 50 years ago that sequencing
wasn't really an option so what they
were working with were
you know fruit flies and ciliates
these little single cell organisms that
live in a little puddle of water and
something that my boss became famous for
was that
when he and his predecessors looked at
these
ciliate organisms they realized that
they have two nuclei
you guys know what nucleus is right okay
cool um so they have two nuclei they
have a micronucleus
which is very tiny and very dark if you
look at it under a microscope
and they have a macronucleus which is
huge and it has seemingly a lot more dna
and the dna is open
and looks like something is going on in
there
and so then they started isolating
proteins from these nuclei and they
realized that
the protein composition is very
different
and while the core proteins are
the same they're modified in a different
way so what am i talking about here
okay so the blue stuff here
that's dna and it's
basically a very long string of a t
g and c and the white stuff
looks like little pucks here that's the
proteins we work on
and they're called histones who has
heard of his stones
yes no one one in chat anybody
yes two excellent so
histones are very small proteins
that are super conserved basically you
can find them
the same histones in you and in a potato
and in a cow and in a fruit fly
and for the most part they are pretty
much identical
and because everything in science
is informed by evolution at least in
biological science
if something is very conserved between a
jellyfish
and a human it means it's really
important like wow important
so when they started looking at these
proteins and it was back in the day
dark ages of science you couldn't just
send everything to a core facility get
the sequence back and like
get your results in the day you had to
run everything by yourself you couldn't
buy kits you had to make your agents
yourself too
they started sequencing these proteins
by hand and they basically started
realizing that oh my god these proteins
are
super conserved they must be super
boring right wow
super boring who cares about a protein
that
is like a potato protein and a human
protein they're identical like who wants
to study that
because everybody was studying dna
watson and crick just
published the dna structure and like
that was the thing
histones were thought to be incredibly
boring just you know packaging material
that dna seems to wrap around
who cares until they did the
studies in these ciliate organisms
little
micronucleus macronucleus
they're called tetrahymena in latin and
these ciliates
happened to have these two nuclei and in
one nucleus
histones carried one kind of mark
and i'll explain what that means and
then the other nucleus
they carried a different kind of mark so
what do i mean by that well turns out
that in the micronucleus
which is tiny dark
doesn't do anything histones carried
something called methylation on them
you guys you guys know chemistry
probably better than i do you're like
super
high achieving students um so
what they were able to deduce is that a
lot of
histones in that dark nucleus
carry the post-translational
modification on them
which means that the protein is the same
but there is a tiny little chemical
group
sitting on one of the amino acids
and micronucleus was very heavily
methylated
whereas in the macronucleus which is
transcriptionally active and it does a
lot of stuff
the histones carried another mark and
that was
acetylation and that's when
things kind of started falling into
place for the histones and their role in
in biology and behind me
i know how much you guys can see that
there is this super ancient white board
um and the sequences on this white board
are actually tails
of four histones there are four histone
proteins and inside the nucleosome there
is
two of each so there's it's an octamer
it's eight proteins
that all fold together and
what people started noticing including
the guy who i work for now
is that these lysines and or
kind of quite a few other amino acids
there they carry these marks
seal up camera acetyl methyl
and depending on where these marks are
and which marks they are the genes are
either on or off
and that became like a huge breakthrough
in understanding
both the function of histones and also
generally like regulation of genes
because now we're thinking about not
just dna
shut the door to the office
because now we're not just talking about
naked dna and you know all of a sudden
you have all these genes and they seem
to be doing the same stuff but
how come some of them are on and some of
them are off well it turns out that the
genes that are off
are decorated by this mark broadly
speaking
and jeans that are on are decorated by
this mark
broadly speaking and of course that
opened up a bunch of other questions
like why
why who who does this who puts these
marks on who puts
those other marks on how do these
writing enzymes they call them writers
how these reading enzymes how do they
get there how do they know which genes
to decorate the right way or
whatever and to be honest we don't know
all the answers um
i shared a couple papers with you
um and feel free to look through them
if you want more in-depth understanding
of this
again in chat who who read anything
did anybody look through this it's okay
if you didn't
um but
this became the era of what's called
epigenetics and we're still in that era
it's still a very hot topic i think
um so ep means above
over on top of and genetics means you
know genetics
so epigenetics means regulation
above dna so what regulates the function
of genes what regulates the
gene expression basically epigenetic
processes
and some people take this term quite
seriously they actually think that
epigenetics means
inheritance um and maybe maybe some of
it is true
we still don't have the definitive
evidence of what's called epigenetic
inheritance
in higher organisms in organisms like
worms and sometimes maybe fruit flies
maybe yeast
changes to histone modifications can
propagate over many generations
so for example a worm raised on certain
kind of food
if it gets used to that kind of food
it's offspring it's
children of their children their
children of their children you know f2
or three or four
they will have the same modifications
over the same sets of genes
when people discover it was like oh my
god we figured it out we figured out
non-mendelian inheritance that's like a
holy grail of epigenetics to figure out
non-mendelian inheritance patterns um
it doesn't seem to hold true in humans
also we don't really have enough data in
humans and also you can't really dissect
humans for your studies with every
generation it's a little more
complicated
um but one thing we do
study a lot and one thing that our lab
has been studying a lot lately
is um human diseases
and specifically
there's something happened in the last
10 years
in biological sciences and
i don't know does anybody want to take a
guess so like what was the biggest
breakthrough in the last
10 years that basically changed our
lives forever
and it's not crispr crispr is cool all
right peter
just go ahead and unmute yourselves and
the human genome was decoded
human genome yes absolutely beyond
that's a that's a great guess and
i was kind of going that way um i was
just going to say
genome-wide sequencing the next
next-generation sequencing
um do we have is does that mean you're
raising your hand or does it mean you're
i have a daily so i have your oh that's
like that's a clap i get it okay i get
it
see i'm terrible at zoom i i don't i
don't
zoom very well um so right
next gen sequencing um and to be honest
human genome they started human genome
with gels they were sequencing with gels
and when they started it they people who
were criticizing that project
thought that people were insane like
it's going to take hundreds of years
and millions and trillions of hours and
dollars and thousands of people to do
that and now
we can sequence human genome like in the
afternoon
um i can do it right here like it's
nothing um it's it's
how far we went is absolutely amazing
and that's basically what happened now
it's a no-brainer if you have
a tumor in a patient to take the tumor
and sequence it
um it's a no-brainer if you have a
patient with developmental disorder
to sequence that patient and as our
numbers of sequenced patients grow
what happens is we can see starting the
patterns because you only have like five
patients if you only have five tumors
you can't really see very much of
anything
that's why nfl games are so
unpredictable because there's only 16 of
them in the season and like it's a small
number you can't really make any
long-term predictions over it if you're
sequencing
thousands and thousands and thousands of
patients essentially every month
over the course of
five years you're going to accumulate
enough data to start seeing patterns
and what i'm talking about here and it's
very relevant to cancer but it also
applies
to developmental disorders schizophrenia
autism you name it
anything um what i'm going to show you
here
is kind of like a little explanation of
what what
what this means so we take the tumor
and we take normal cells and normal
cells are usually
just peripheral blood cells or you can
take them from the tumor biopsy as well
and then you sequence both and
if you noticed i basically compiled the
list of
mutations so on this on this side
there's these lines
and the vertical lines basically mean
there's a mutation in that position
and no genome is completely free of
differences from reference like every
one of us is different by
every thousand bases there is a mutation
so it's really important to do
this the this control the normal cells
um but then if you compare normal
cells from the same patient to the tumor
cells in that same patient
very likely you're going to start seeing
differences
and these differences are usually
numbering in hundreds if not thousands
but if you do more than five patients
you can start seeing really interesting
patterns
and these patterns can be like this for
example
you can have a protein in
a tumor and so i drew out here
a structure of a protein and all of a
sudden
in this position we have lots of
patients
who have mutations so what does that
tell you
somebody anybody
unmute yourself
that if there's a lot of mutations in
that area then that might be the
direct cause of the tumor yeah that's a
good guess it tells you that that's
probably important
right that's something to to to look at
you don't know the direct cause yet but
that's a very good guess and that if you
see something like that that's wow
that's
that's really cool that's promising you
want to study that
you can also start seeing that let's say
every patient
with that particular tumor has
a mutation in a protein but mutations
are
randomly distributed in that one protein
or and that that also tells you
something and like this
in the first case scenario this tells
you that this particular domain
or this particular area of the protein
is really important
there are proteins like that in cancer
this is the second case scenario
which tells you that it's maybe not a
domain of a protein that's important
but the protein itself is like really
really important
and any mutation in this protein
can be very detrimental to the patient
and probably not quite it's actually the
opposite
very beneficial to the tumor because it
makes the tumor grow
if you guys have heard about protein
called p53 you've probably heard about
p53
so p53 looks like this
it's mutated in half of all cancers and
mutations are
all over the place if you heard about
the protein called ras
it's also mutated in i don't know 30 40
of all cancers
uh it it looks like this in fact it
doesn't even look like that it looks
just like one mutation
that one mutation is just
so detrimental so terrible that you can
get cancer
you can get another kind of mutation and
that's the other way around you can have
basically blank areas in the proteins
and that tells you that that part of the
protein is
just important for viability you cannot
have
that part mutated going back to the
histones why are histones conserved
between
potatoes and humans well it's because
they're so important that any mutation
in these proteins
is very poorly tolerated and you you
don't get any benefits from
having that mutated so evolution is kind
of like always in our back
of our minds we always think about
what's the you know pressures what is
the benefits of this mutation why does
this mutation exist
um all right
tell me something you guys
want to know in the next minute i'm
going to take a little break
talking and maybe you guys can tell me
what do you know about epigenetics
what do you know about histones what do
you know about cancer biology
and if i can answer any of your
questions and after that i will go back
talking about
histone mutations and then we're going
to take a little tour around the lab
because actually it's like already 10
30 um and time flies real real fast
does that sound good
okay all right so one of each one of you
go ahead unmute yourselves and um
maybe maybe ask me questions maybe i can
tell you how i
came to this lab um
yeah there we go there's like 40 of you
guys come on
you can you can you probably have
questions uh
well so i was reading the
like the just the like overview of what
you guys
do in this lab on the on
yeah and it says at the begin
like it mentions some enzymatic
processes at the beginning and i
would just like to know all right what
are these like
facilitation methylation phosphorylation
and everything yeah so
um how deep do you need to go in this
i uh all right so we can go pretty right
so when we talk about histones
and when we talk about all enzymatic
processes and the whole
concept of these um in
biology that we study is
i mean there's this pretty artificial
division between
readers writers and erasers right
and it's artificial because the same
enzyme
can be a reader and an eraser and maybe
a writer too
and if you're writing a mark above a
mark then you are also an eraser and
reader and a writer at the same time
because you have to
figure all these marks out at the same
time um so what what happens with
histones and what happens with
our genome that's packaged by histones
that histones are decorated by
dozens if not hundreds
of different enzymatic modifications on
them
and the enzymes that do that obviously
have to
come to the right place at the right
time put this mark
and then either leave or move on to the
next
unit because this is really what
chromatin looks like
people who have studied this using
electron microscopes many years ago
they've realized that it looks like
beads on a string
and the beads are nucleosomes and the
string is dna and basically
dna is wrapped around nucleosomes and
it's interpreted by the cell
in context of these nucleosomes
so these enzymes that work on dna
we don't have a lot of high quality
imaging studies on them so if you guys
won't ever
go ahead and do that like that'll be
super cool i'm sure technology will
catch up
um they have to go from one nucleosome
to another
and they have to modify them in certain
ways
um there are like let me just share a
screen with you real quick
um and uh
share screen so this is the structure
all right can you can you see my screen
with a ribbon diagram moving around
all right excellent so this is a
structure i shared with you in that
email as well
and this is basically a nucleosome
all right so that's what it looks like
if you
look at the dna and if you look at how
the proteins
are folded inside it
oh sorry hold on i have a random
incoming spam phone call
on all right so there are
four histone types they're all folded
together into this
beautiful ribbon structure and then
there's the fifth histone type which is
called linker histone which sits just
outside the nucleosome
and basically every one of them
looks like this now histones also have
tails
and the tails are what's drawn on that
structure over there on that board over
there
but they can be modified inside the core
of the nucleosome
or they can be modified on the tails and
these tails also they look kind of like
antennas that
sense the stuff you can't see the tails
in the structure simply because
they're floppy they're not they don't
have a structure they're just everywhere
they sample the environment
um to give you an example of what
an enzyme will look like when it's
reading or writing these modifications
here's another structure and this is a
much
worse quality structure but it made
big waves in science when it was
published
this is a very important complex
called polycom i'm
not sure you have heard of it but if you
do study anything epigenetic
you probably have heard about it
um so this is the nucleosome and this is
another nucleosome
and what this polycom complex does is it
senses a modification on one nucleosome
it still shows the previous structure oh
sorry sorry sorry hold on new share
ah there we go how about that
excellent all right so here we go so we
have two nucleosomes now
i know why it's because i opened it in a
different window and i'm still sharing
the same with them okay cool
so this is the same ribbon diagram
um and it senses one nucleosome here
and then it reaches over and if you zoom
all the way in you see this blue line
that's the histone
and then you don't really see it and
then you see it again over here and
that's a histone tail
and this histone tail is going to get
modified the methyl mark is going to get
put on it
by this enzyme that's shown here in pink
or magenta
and this complex has at least four
different subunits they're very
complicated there is
probably five more that come around and
do other things
um this complex is very heavily mutated
in some cancers
including on lymphomas and the mutations
just like in this one of the picture i
showed you
the mutations in lymphomas all happen
right here
in this catalytic center
and this enzyme just goes crazy and it
starts putting mark over and over and
over and over again
on normally it's regulated and in
lymphomas it just
goes goes nuts now polycom is very
special
and it's very historic and very
interesting because
when it was discovered people actually
didn't
know about histones and histone
modifications
it was discovered by a guy and actually
his wife um forgetting her name um
his his last name was louis her last
name was lewis too
um they were screening fruit flies
for mutations that affected their body
patterning
because they were interested in
regulation of how how are body
patterns specified why how does the fly
know to grow
six legs and how does it grow
two legs on each body segment and not
an extra pair of wings and all that kind
of stuff
and so he was looking for mutations that
changed that pattern and he basically
had flies that have
extra pair of wings extra pair of
you know leg segments extra pair of
abdominal segments
he ended up winning nobel prize for
those studies by the way
and just by genetics just by crossing
these flies together
he figured out that there is a
complex of proteins that does
something to repress a set of genes he
didn't know how it does it
and i'll tell you another cool story
about it in a second
but he and he called it polycom because
the phenotype of these flies they had
extra bristle combs on their legs i mean
who would notice an extra bunch of
bristles on legs or a fruit fly right
but the name stuck and we're all stuck
with that name
and polycom is probably the hottest
enzymatic
complex in histone biology now
but here's a super cool story so there
is a repressor complex in flies and
humans
that in flies was identified
on a chromosome 3 on
i think on a band nine of the chromosome
and it's called suvar three nine
suvar means suppressor of variegation
it's a very genetic term it's just the
screen type
in which this protein was identified
three nine and here's the super cool
part
when 30 years later they figured out how
that complex works
do you know what it does it modifies
lysine on histone three in position nine
it's just a coincidence but it's super
cool i mean it's a hand of god type
situation
um suvar three nine and everybody who
you talk to now they're like oh yes
r39 is called that because it's it's the
histone h3
and lysine ix methyl transferase like no
no no they named it
30 years before they knew what it does
and it's just an accident that the name
kind of
matches so well anyway
so this this is what the enzymatic
complex
looked like and the structure was made
just about a year ago
we finally have the tools to do this
kind of stuff um
so any more questions i'm going to stop
sharing
this and i will
get back to the screen
do you think so our class uh we just
kind of started talking about protein
folding and stuff like that can you tell
us a little bit about
how you get a structure like that
like the one you just showed us okay
yeah so
there there is two ways and there really
has been i'm gonna
i'm gonna keep sharing this because it's
just such a beautiful structure or i can
just show you
on the wall there's a cross stitch
of that structure too you probably can
see it
right over there um my boss's children
are
in the army and so we have like army and
navy walls but we also have
uh cross stitches of random nucleus
homes
so this there's there's
two things in that question first is how
does the protein
fold correctly in the cell and
to be honest we don't really know
there is a lot of talk about chaperones
um and obviously chaperones are super
important there's a lot of proteins that
come in and make sure protein
stays in certain conformation during
folding
it becomes quite complex when we're
talking about multi-protein structure
for example
the nucleosome because we have
essentially eight different proteins
that have to get together in the right
time in the right place
what's curious about nucleosome is that
you can actually purify histones from
bacteria
which we do routinely in the lab every
day and if you add them in the right
order
with the fragment of dna they will just
fold themselves into a nucleus home
they they know how they know i don't
know but
they find their partners and just
energetically seems like there's this
one absolutely optimal confirmation
that you can then figure out you might
have heard about this something super
cool that also happened in the last
couple days
there was a google ai
alpha i mean i know alpha star because i
play starcraft
but alpha something
that apparently is approaching
the what scientists can do
experimentally
now you can deduce domain structure
by just plugging that sequence into that
google alpha
ai system which is super scary and also
super duper cool
um i don't know it's all neural networks
and
stuff that's like this um
yeah it's like machines are coming for
us
like they are um so i'm gonna try
and figure out how to share this thing
again um there we go
but then another quest so one question
is how do proteins know how to how to
solve this
structure right and somehow they do we
don't know the answer another
question is how do scientists know what
this looks like
and that i can tell you more about and
the answer is
until very recently with you did
something called x-ray crystallography
and to do that you have to have very
pure protein
and you have to figure out a condition
in which
this very pure protein will assemble
into a essentially what what what's a
crystal right a crystal is a
packed unit where each cell
is attached to adjacent cells in a
stereotypical way
if so if you play with salt play with
detergents
play with solution
amounts and concentrations and usually
people who do that they do it in a very
large scale way they have
robots doing that these robots just look
like boxes so they're not like
cool robots from futurama they're
actually very boring robots
and you have to put a bunch of solutions
in them and they pipet
tiny tiny droplets or these solutions
and then you wait
and then a month later you screen
through these plates and you look for
crystals
and if you're lucky you will have
crystals growing and that means that
you're close to conditions
in which the proteins can crystallize
this was also discovered long time ago
on people who first discovered it did it
i think for hemoglobin
and they also won nobel prize for it but
what they did was that they
put a beam of x-ray and they do
x-ray because x-ray has much shorter
wavelength
and so if you put like regular light
over obviously the
distances between the atoms in this
structure are
on the order of angstroms so it's one
tenth of a nanometer it's very very very
close
like you can sort of zoom in and i can
randomly color like a
sample so let's do a
residue and we can highlight the residue
hold on i have zoom interface over me um
color
reds and we will
on sticks so there we go
so this looks like a tyrosine this is an
amino acid
is that a tyrosine i'm going to double
check myself yes it is
um so this is a tyrosine
and it has this ring and this ring has
atomic density
that by shining x-ray light at the
crystal
you can collect the scatter pattern and
you can resolve that
um at first they did it by hand and it
took
years to just match the dots
to possible distances between atoms and
you couldn't really do it with
complex structures like this
as time goes on obviously you know we go
from
like regular radio to an iphone 12g
whatever and now we we
we can plug it into a computer and the
computer does the math much better than
a regular person can so that was x-ray
the problem with x-ray crystallography
is actually a huge problem
you have to have a crystal and that's
hard
like that the biggest problem is not to
resolve the crystal it
can resolve anything the problem is to
grow it
and the bigger your protein is and the
harder it is to purify your protein
the less chances are you're going to
grow a crystal ever and people spend
years and years and years like
pursuing that for some proteins and they
could never grow a crystal
um i mean science that's how science
works right you spend years doing
something and then
[Music]
it doesn't work um
it's it's actually quite quite sad and
funny
when it's not happening to you um i
guess so but then
a few years ago something happened and
what happened again was this big data
revolution um and the big data came in
terms of image analysis
and once people had the capacity to
analyze
images at a like insane
scale of millions and millions of
millions of photographs at the same time
it's the kind of the same software that
can do the facial recognition and
license plate identification on the cars
it happened at the same time they also
realized that they can take pictures
with electron microscope
of the same beads on the string i was
telling you about
so what you do is you take your proteins
and it can be a very large protein
complex now
it can be a protein complex that's very
hard to purify it doesn't matter
you put a very thin layer on the slide
and you plug it into the cryo electron
microscope
so at very very cold temperatures
the electron light same electron light
shines on these protein complexes and
you get the
actual photograph and then you take
these photographs and you take
millions like not millions but like tens
of thousands hundreds of thousands of
them
you plug them into software software
starts figuring out are there any
stereotypical patterns
and the more photographs you take the
more precise can software be
and actually the structure i was showing
you for the polycom complex
that's how it was obtained so now the
electron densities
can be derived from just a photograph
and that has revolutionized
crystallography everybody who is doing
x-ray crystals
is now out of job not really but
they they have to change their ways and
people who know how to operate these
cryoelectron microscopes
are absolutely you know
top scientists and so on they won nobel
prize for that technology as well
and now with google ai on the way i
think
five years down the road they will be
looking for jobs too
so that's that's progress that's how it
works
and that's quite exciting um so
that's that that's how these structures
are derived
um what what i personally do
is i then look at the structures i
derived one structure in my lifetime
that was very long time ago when i was
in graduate school
it's long it's it takes a long time it
like it looks super cool
but if you're working on this um you're
gonna spend
months figuring out if this atom is
aligned
one way or slightly off
and again we're talking about all of
these maps all of these cool looking
models they're essentially probabilities
like what we do is we say yeah this is
the likely structure
is it always like this i don't know i'm
not sure
um but that's that's that's where we're
at
um and i guess what i was going to tell
you about
i was going to tell you about cancer and
histones
and i can do that real quick i have 10
more minutes
or i can just walk you through the lab
and i can show you our
wet lab part which to be honest in
biochemistry labs they're
quite boring there's there's nothing
there that's like
oh my god we don't have this giant
microscope but even if we did have a
giant microscope
all you're going to see is just the
tubes and
the big white box so
whatever you guys want i can talk for 10
more minutes about histones and cancer
or i can talk i can just walk you
through the lab with a
cell phone and you get to meet the lab
mates
so i'll stop the screen sharing in
i don't i don't
really prefer either one i'd be fine
without you
okay
lab tour all right lab tour it is laptop
wins
okay stop the count
lab tour
i will unmute myself
can you guys hear me
i'm gonna switch the camera
yeah we can hear you all right excellent
so now
i will walk through the lab and this is
basically
the office space whichever lab has in
its most important part
as you guys know and
here is some equipment
and here is a machine that lets you
calculate
how quickly the genes are expressed and
how many of them are expressed and
how what's the expression level
it's called quantitative pcr
there are some people working hard
this is what a wet lab looks like
and some of you might have seen a tank
or
something called western blot this is
basically a
polyacrylamide gel
it's a polyacrylamide gel that you load
the proteins into
and then you apply a current
and basically what happens the proteins
run through the polyacrylamide gel
at different speeds because they're
different size
and then you can get them out of the gel
and identify them using antibody
here's more lab i don't think anybody is
working with anything cool right now the
coolest thing we have done in the lab is
probably mousework
and here are other postdocs in the lab
um and
here's our adventures in our workspaces
and to be honest the coolest part here
is just little
centrifuges and occasional reagents
oh look at that this is cell suspension
and these cells will get spun down
and i don't think you can ever see the
pellet um so what are you going to do
with these cells
oh there we go
there we go so that's exactly that we're
gonna do western vlog
we do a lot of westerns in the lab um
these are shaker incubators where we
grow bacteria
you can grow them at different
temperatures
these are tanks where we store
oh yeah hang on
it's the masks yes so
this is the temperature
and this is super duper cool this is
where we store the cells
and it's liquid nitrogen
boom minus 142.
um
this is the this is the tissue culture
room and
it might get a little spotty with the
coverage here
because i think this is where our
networks fail
this is what the cells look like when we
draw them in culture you can't actually
see the cells
um but that's that's the plates and
that's the
clean food
and then this is where they live you can
grow
regular cells you can grow cancer cells
yeah and it looks really
dry but like a little rusty
but that's actually copper and copper is
killing bacteria and fungi
so the the copper lining of the
incubator is actually quite good
and i'm going to show you a couple more
things in another room and chances are
you guys are going to break off here
because we don't have very good coverage
here on the network um but here is
the part of the lab where we sometimes
work with radioactivity
like if you ever want to trace
a special protein that you're interested
in sometimes the easiest way to do so
is to put in a radioactive amino acid
into it
and then you can track it you'll always
be able to find it
i guess i can't even open this because
it's frozen shut oh very good
and that's that's how you store that
stuff like this is not chernobyl
level radiation but it still still has
to be stored in a very special
way so there's that uh we have to
dispose of radioactive
materials a certain way so
it goes into special containers
and it just lives there until somebody
picks them up
these are centrifuges if you want to
separate
different proteins or different parts of
the cell
you can spin them at like this is the
speed so that's
rounds per minute that's how quickly the
centrifuge will go
um and you need a pretty strong motor
and
vacuum and all this stuff and then
there's a bunch of other random
oh yeah washing machine so so here's the
funny thing about this
because when it works this
thing like the rotor is spinning
obviously the super high speed
one thing you should never do when the
centrifuge is spinning
is moving and
it happens and actually i'm not sure if
i can
turn it on to open it
if you look inside the rotor inside the
chamber here
there's this big bump in the chamber
and that's because somebody moved the
centrifuge
when it was on and the rotor just
ran off this axis that it was spinning
on
and slammed into the wall it was like a
big
big disaster well disasters happen in
the lab all the time
so these are machines again to separate
proteins this is called
hplc it's liquid chromatography
you can separate more than proteins
using these we used up proteins
so what happens it's the same same
principle as the gel that we use for the
western blots
but in this case we inject proteins into
this machine
and they run through this little device
it's a column
with media and different proteins get
stuck
at different times and so you start with
a mix of proteins but as you
go this they go through the column for
example small proteins will grow first
large proteins will grow last and then
you can
you can harvest these proteins into
these little tubes
different fractions and then you can
isolate these fractions and
you know do all kinds of science with
them if you need to break
oh yeah
there we go that's the view
we don't get to look out of the window
very much but this is our view
that's the view
and that's the cold room that's that's
where we store stuff that's where we do
some experiments too
like it's a basically a big room that's
set to four degrees
we have another one that's used to be
set to 37 degrees
but right now we just it's basically
turned into storage room because we
don't work with these little celliats
anymore that i
told you about while ago so i'm going to
switch
to my own face
no hold on there we go
and i'm going to return back to the
office because it is already 11 o'clock
and i think you guys have another class
in about a minute or i don't know how
school works these days
um yes while i'm walking
off with a couple questions
uh very educational
okay i will turn this off
if you guys like looking at the
equipment wait till the pandemic is over
and
come back come come to actual labs the
thing is think about lab equipment
all equipment is the same in every lab
you don't have to come to rockefeller to
look at the centrifuge
um i think nora had a question about how
did you get in
field yeah so
i grew up in russia i
went to school there and then um
basically the choice was do i go to
biology
in college or do i do medicine
and then russia system is completely
different it's not like med school is
like super prestigious or anything
but still like biology teachers make
nothing and doctors
can can make a little bit more um and so
i went to med school
while not really wanting to do medicine
and then when i was probably my fourth
year there in in med school in russia i
um basically got an internship in a
research lab in u.s
and i came to the us for like a little
four year four four month
stint i almost failed my med school
exams because of that
in russia because i missed like four
months out of like a year
um and i loved it i was super excited i
actually i did the protein
crystallography
i was very happy to do that i and i i
came back for grad school two years
later
and i worked on fruit flies um studied
fly
or genesis and how the
o site is specified and how female
fertility sterility works in fruit flies
and then after that i realized that you
know
stuff that happens in the nucleus is
probably the most important part
um so i have i want to study that and if
you want to study stuff in the nucleus
you
you really want to start with this
um and then i i came here
i think as in colleges too you you apply
to multiple different places you
interviewed multiple different places
and you basically see what's the better
fit
i thought i would work on small rnas
when i was in college
uh micrornas and si rnas were like super
hot
everybody loved small rnas and i i
rotated in the lab that studied them and
i was like no this is boring
but
that's okay what i find boring i'm sure
some people will be like oh my god this
is the most exciting thing in the world
so
i'm not judging i'm just like not for me
that's all
anything else protein structure is
important
enzymes are important substrates are
important
amino acids if you know that difference
between lysine
and glutamic acid you know more than
most people so you got to know k's
rs e's and d's
and that's all and also you know the
glycine breaks the alpha helix
that's also cool if you put a glycine
into a protein it will break the helix
yes centrifuges so when i
when i worked in russia we didn't have
these nice centrifuges like we had a
plastic centrifuge that was really
terrible but we figured out a way how to
isolate dna on that centrifuge
and we we did that and i don't wish that
upon anyone but we did that
we washed the pipette tips and we washed
the tubes too that was hilarious
i worked in a research institute that
the project was we studied
tuberculosis in hiv positive patients
and we washed the tips and plastic
from our biomaterial here it would be
like a
biosafety level three probably you would
need to wear a full hazmat suit to work
with that and there it's like yeah
like let's wash three reuse it
wow that is
not easy
wow
so you sequenced it or how
how did you figure that out wow
so there is there there's a lot of
interesting math with dna right dna is
only four base pairs and it's the same
base pairs all across the animal kingdom
there is one interesting hint you can
get very quickly from
dna because some organisms methylate
their dna and some don't
for example if you work with humans like
10 of our cytosines are methylated they
have methyl cytosine
instead and oh yeah you can do specific
pc of primers of course
but for example if you work with fruit
flies
they don't have dna methylation and so
it's really funny when people are trying
to use fruit flies as a model for a lot
of epigenetic processes
and i love fruit flies i worked with
them for a long time but
you cannot always study human stuff in
fruit flies just because they don't have
the same regulatory systems
but obviously if you realize that you
don't have dna methylation in your
sample
you know that this is not human dna this
is like fruit fly dna or something like
that
another interesting question is if human
genome is
i know three billion base pairs long
how long should the primer be to be
specific
and you have like two primers right so
you can do the math i can give you the
answer
whatever um it's it's actually quite
interesting because
um it's it's an important consideration
because when you do
a pcr from bacterial dna or especially
bacterial plasmid which is
you know 10 000 base pairs
even a six base fragment only really
happens once
when you do a pcr from a human dna
you really have to make sure your
primers are specific and that they're
long enough
that they only happen only a couple
times in the genome because
let's say they happen twice but you only
get a product
if your primers are in the same locus if
they
run into each other
yes so the jelly line substance that's
agarose gel
so agarose um actually the guy who
invented this i met him in person he
he was super old by them his name was
oliver smithey's
um he was like really funny old
dude um he came up with the idea to
resolve
dna fragments in starch so he had
like potato starch or corn starch i
think it was potato starch back then
um and he made this jelly and he put dna
in there and
applied currant and you could see that
small fragments run faster than big ones
again because big ones yep yeah yeah so
big ones get
stuck and small ones just wiggle right
through
[Music]
and then as technology progressed they
replaced the
starch gel which is super fragile it
breaks apart very
quickly they replace the starch gel with
agarose gel and agarose is obviously
much easier to work with you can make
nice
stuff and shapes out of it
yeah i know you guys are lucky you've
seen all these things i first saw that
when i was
in not so much even in college i i came
to the lab and i'm like oh my god this
is ethedium
dna this is magic you know with
fluorescence
super cool and then like of course you
don't know all the precautions so
you start looking at it without the
face shield and anything and then like
why are my eyes itching
like okay i know why they're itching
because
because i was looking at the gels for 30
minutes
um when you guys have to go i can keep
talking forever like just
just let me know cut me off
i don't hear anything is anybody talking
yeah i mean um definitely our class is
over um does anybody have
any other questions to finish up we have
a double period so
they don't have to yeah oh okay cool
yeah we do like the first half is
together and the second half is
asynchronous so
so so where do you want to be when
you're finished there's a question in
chat
that is a great question um to be honest
i don't know
i'm applying for jobs right now and when
i say i'm applying for jobs i'm applying
for jobs in academia
as a lab head as a
person who will run his own lab i
just had an interview in england i just
scheduled an interview in nih
national institutes of health um
we'll see how it goes this year has been
really weird
because teaching universities are
essentially not hiring
so the amount of jobs that are out there
are pretty
but on the other hand um a lot of people
are not going on the job market this
year so
just you know might as well try it out
um
i have a wife and i have two kids my
wife is also a scientist she's a postdoc
at nyu
just you know 30 blocks that way
um we have to coordinate how we apply
for jobs because if i get a job in
england
and she stays in new york with
can we leave yeah you can you can feel
free to leave i'm not
clocking anybody's hours um yeah so
so it's it's an interesting stuff with
academia i think
the draw of academia is that you're sort
of your own boss
you do your own things and you
kind of like make your own schedule the
downside is that you spend 25
plus years in school you are super
overqualified
and you know this like one little thing
better than anybody else in the world
but does anybody care like that's
another question right and like
and then like do do you make an impact
too like that's also something you ask
yourself like if you're studying fruit
flyogenesis for the rest of your life
does it matter and sometimes it does you
know the guys who who studied the
bacterial immunity systems right they
were like oh this is so cool we have
this bacteria with strange looking dna
sequences that repeat themselves
let's call them clustered repeats
interspersed
elements blah blah blah something like
cool
and then 10 years later somebody else
was like wait a second
we can repurpose that and edit human
genome or like any genome like
this and all of a sudden that's the
hottest thing in the world and this is
super cool
why are fruit flies used so much that's
a great question
they are historical on
louis the 14th in his court had fruit
flies
and they were looking at their eye color
and that was cool
but also and of course the thomas hunt
morgan the the guy from caltech
who used fruit flies he was a very
prolific scientist and
people he trained every single one of
them went to be like a nobel prize
winning
or deserving scientist who did fantastic
job in fruit flies so
basically the basis of our animal
genetics
was laid out in fruit flies white was
fertilized and not worms
just the sheer luck he could have
studied it and see elegance and worms
he would have done it in some other
organism there is
i mean it's a mix of history and just
utility flies are very useful
the generation time is just 14 days
they live literally on garbage like the
fly food is
corn sugar and
yeast and water and you mix that and you
boil it and you pour it into vials and
you can have that vial they live for 90
days you can watch them for a long
enough time
um they propagate almost indefinitely
it's very hard to kill them literally
like
you you have to try very hard to kill
your flies i've done that
accidentally um so
they're they're very useful models um
and
also inertia right by now there is such
a bank of mutants
they're so well characterized that
sometimes you want to study something
you're like
huh i wonder if there's a fly mutant for
that and probably there is and
you just go in and you figure out what
people already published on it and
sometimes you inform your decisions
based on
on that mutant we do more mouse work
because mice are a lot closer to humans
just in everything they have dna
methylation among other things
but now with the next gen sequencing and
i i'm not sure
that point really came across because i
was kind of talking very quickly uh
the what what we base a lot of our
hypotheses on
is just patient sequencing data there is
enough resources out there that you can
go in and just
look up a specific type of cancer or
your favorite protein
and you can find which cancers is
mutated in or
which cancers have a mutation in
whatever else you want to study
and for example histone mutations like
something that happened in the last 10
years
less than 10 years is that they have
started finding mutations
in these very tails and very specific
mutations
um histones are very funny because
you know normally you have one gene per
protein and that's like
dogma so for most histones there's about
between
13 and 15 genes for each histone
so that makes histone genetics very
complicated because
you can't just make a null on knockout
right you have to
make 15 knockouts sometimes on the same
chromosome which just
impossible to do um there are ways
around it but it's very very hard
but what you can do now is you can just
look at patient data sets
and that's your genetic that's your
workbench essentially
instead of growing flies and running
these screens and flies
you look at thousands of cancers and you
find like oh my god this particular
residue
is mutated in like 90 percent of
patients with
glioma for example and that's that's
true the this k27 lysine 27
on h3 tail i'm pointing at it like i
just i can't even find it right now i
think it's all well you can't
see it but it's there it's on these
tails um it is
uh mutated specifically to methionine
in patients with these gliomas and these
are pediatric patients
which invariably it's a lethal cancer
you can you can't cure it
and since we found that mutation
in the last five years we've actually
come very very close to figuring out
what we can do to fix it
so you know five more years we might be
able to fix it you know it's not going
to help people who have it now but it
might help somebody
five ten years down the road and it all
started with the
lewis experiments with like a fly with
extra bristles on
its leg you know
so that's that's how it works and
science is fun
well i think that's a great note to end
on potentially that science is
fun and there are really cool things um
that you know
will come from this research over the
next several years so thank you so so
much for talking to us and showing us
around your lab we really appreciate it
um and yeah thanks again and students i
will see you
tomorrow thanks for being around and
thanks for listening
uh if you if you got like one tenth of
what i rambled about that would be
fantastic
so thank you
you